[Music]
hello and welcome to stormtrooper
training
my name is off giddy but you can call me
off what the am i doing welcome to think
stories episode 7 breakdown of the
Mandalorian where the only thing more
scuffed than my intros are these
stormtroopers armor in this video we'll
be breaking down the penultimate episode
and you'll want to stay around till the
very end as will be going over theories
on how this season will end so grab some
tea because here we go our first images
of the razor crest zipping through the
galaxy after having successfully ran
away from brand warding his plan to take
him down baby Yoda is dreaming away when
a message comes in to mando its grief
cargo the head of the Bounty Hunter
guild on Navarro who he last saw got
shot in episode 3 this is a new message
not to be confused with the one zero
found which was the same one from
episode 3 notifying the Mandalorian that
the client is eager to get his hands on
the child because that scene was zero
and griefs hologram didn't add anything
to the plot he was either put there for
one of two reasons a to remind us about
grief and set us up for this episode or
be it's used as a device so that zero
and the other bounty hunters know about
the child and might show up in future
episodes well just like Apollo Creed
patches things up with rocky grief wants
to let bygones be bygones and proposes a
deal should he bring back the child to
Navarro since mandos abrupt departure
from the planet the former Imperial
soldiers under the rule of the client
have imposed despotic rule over the city
which hasn't been good for business if
the Mandalorian agrees to kill the
client using the child as bait to lure
him out grief will make sure mandos name
is cleared with the guild it's a win-win
mando gets to keep the child and put a
stop to the unending parade of bounty
hunters after him
well grief gets his business back mando
knows what he has to do agreeing to this
deal is the only way he can make sure
the child is safe chapter 7 is called
the reckoning the avenging or punishing
of past mistakes which is what happens
to the Mandalore in this episode it's
time to pay for what he's done but
before heading back to Navarro the
Mandalorian stops on sorg in the planet
where he
in Cara Doon fought off the 80s t car is
pretty strapped for cash resorting to
fighting as a brac for some extra
credits
I think this electrical tether thing is
pretty cool which makes sure the
fighters are always within a certain
distance from one another when one of
the fighters wants to tap out they tap
the tether which releases them we also
get a better look a Taser Brack here a
human-like species from the planet
iridonia they grow these horns during
puberty and many of them have facial
tattoos which they receive during the
rite of passage fun fact for you kinky
people out there Sam Brooks can actually
mate with humans mando gets down to
business asking car to join him on
taking down the client he can even
provide passage there and back on the
razor crest and a handsome reward she
initially turns him down but once she
hears that the client is Imperial she's
all in car was a shock trooper for the
Republic and fought Imperials as a
mercenary she's seen what they're
capable of so this mission becomes
somewhat personal for her Cara takes in
the Mandalorians weapon cache and asks
why he's taking on such a risky mission
he has no choice what's he gonna do run
away from the client for the rest of his
life always unsure if someone is on his
tail it's here that baby Yoda decides to
play pilot and mando realizes he's gonna
need a babysitter so he heads to the
planet with the best eggs in the galaxy
to meet with the ugh not queal quill
examines the child he doesn't think it's
engineered since he's worked on gene
farms and hasn't seen anything like it
Cara however looks like she was farmed
on this site ok visib Nora which I'm
assuming is a compliment we learn a bit
more about quills past here it's
actually pretty sad making it all the
more tragic when we find out what
happens to him at the end of the episode
quill spent the equivalent of three
human lifetimes an indentured servant to
the Imperials for what he called a debt
his clan had to pay he eventually was
able to gain his own freedom in walks IG
11 the same droid from episode one and
man was about to shoot the crap out of
him because that droids mission was to
kill the child
but quill says he's been reprogrammed
and now helps with more mundane tasks
like pouring tea this doesn't sit well
with the Mandalorian considering his
absolute distrust of droids
I believe IG 11 will join the
Mandalorians crew especially now since
squeal is seemingly dead this will allow
the Mandalorian to overcome
distrust of them and grow as a character
queal agrees to join the mandalorian not
for payment but to protect the child
from getting into the hands of the
Imperials he knows all too well what
it's like to be a slave thus his motive
is personal just like Cara's that's one
thing I love about the writing on this
show the characters goals aren't
superficial they're rooted in their
personal backstories this means their
goals come with stakes there's a cost to
them heightening the overall emotional
impact of the narrative mando and Cara
arm-wrestle but the child interprets
this as Cara hurting mando so he goes
full Darth Vader in force chokes her
this is the first time since the mud
horn in Episode two that we've seen the
child uses powers Cara cleans her
blaster in preparation for the mission
telling the Mandalorian that Navarro
stayed in Imperial control until the war
was over it's still a hotbed of Imperial
activity mando tell squeal that IG 11 is
not supposed to leave the ship under any
circumstances but I won't be surprised
if he sees a dead cui land ventures out
next episode as his programming tells
him he has to protect ironically in a
lot of ways idea Levin's journey mimics
that of the Mandalorians if a droid who
was programmed to kill can change and
become a protector can a bounty hunter
like himself do the same thing the razor
crest lands with grief and three of his
henchmen waiting I love how he's still
wearing the same vest he got shot in
with the blaster mark clearly visible
grief recommends that car should stay
her tattoos clearly show she's no friend
of the Imperials and the last thing they
need is a town filled with stormtroopers
on high alert for those of you who may
have missed it she has a visible rebel
tattoo on her cheek and apparently
there's an origin story that we haven't
gotten into yet mando shows grief the
child and they decide to make camp
before heading into town grief can't
believe this green thing thinking he's
wanted as a rare creature for someone's
menagerie as he'll soon find out the
child is much more important the plan is
pretty simple enter the client's place
with mando as bait kill the client and
get out of there there shouldn't be more
than four troopers so that was why and
as soon as grief says nothing can go
wrong a pack of pterodactyl like
creatures attack from above and gravely
injured him not only is they cut deep
it's also poisonous and spreading fast
enter the child who we seed performed
Jesus healing powers and fix grief good
as new now the show did hint at the
child having healing powers all the way
back in episode 2 after the mud horn
fight the Mandalorian bandages himself
up when the child attempts to help him
but before he can he's popped back into
his crib as they approached the town it
looks like the Mandalorians about to be
backstabbed until grief kills the two
remaining bounty hunters his plan
originally was to kill the mandalorian
and take the kid but after seeing what
it could do and that he now owes his
life to it he's had a change of heart
the Mandalorian spares griefs life and
continues on with the mission
queel has given the child and sent back
to the Razr quest for safety this
comlink will allow the mandalorian to
keep in contact with queal during the
mission but it's also the device the
signal of which gets intercepted by
these stormtroopers who later hunt down
and shoot queal at the entrance to town
grief provides his chain code we've
heard mention of chain codes in episode
1 when the client is only able to give
the Mandalorian the last four digits of
the child's chain code which tells his
age it seems these chain codes are the
Star Wars equivalent of ID cards at the
town cantina grief meets with the client
the client admires the Mandalorians new
armor which he crafted using the cam
Tona
best car steal he received for returning
the child he also makes an impassioned
speech about the Empire's grip on the
galaxy why wouldn't a planet where
people want to be controlled by them the
Empire brings advancements in every
metric to every planet that they touch
why would people resist this what he's
really getting at is the question of
freedom would you give your freedom up
for this now that the Empire is gone the
galaxy has descended into death and
chaos further justifying his monologue
but before the client gets to see the
baby he receives a call from Moff Gideon
the real man pulling the strings and
watching the child because this is Star
Wars I wouldn't be surprised if there's
someone even above him that wants the
child as well the Mandalorian takes off
his cuffs and grief passes him a blaster
in preparation for the fight ahead but
out of the blue moth and his men blast
through the cantina shooting right
through the client alongside Moff are
some death troopers who we see here in
black they are an elite
version of the stormtrooper who are
often used for stealth and espionage
missions as well as bodyguards for
high-ranking Imperial officers mando
asks if quill made it back to the ship
but the signal is dead along with queal
apparently he wants the razor crest to
help save them which leads me to believe
that
IG 11 may come and help next episode
Moff Gideon tells mando and Cara that
soon the thing they have will belong to
him and then it means more to him than
they'll ever know we see poor baby Yoda
snatched up by one of the storm troopers
with the episode ending on a seemingly
dead queal mando completely surrounded
with no way out along with the razor
crest possibly helping them next episode
there is also the pram remember that
mando asked squeal to install some quote
extra padding in it which I think could
be code word for a secret compartment we
also saw cara hold up this bomb when
looking at the mandos weapons so it's
entirely possible the pram could be
filled with explosives or weapons which
might be able to make a big enough
explosion to distract and allow them to
get away in the trailer we see the
Mandalorian hanging onto Mothe Gideon's
ship with his grappling line so it looks
like moth does make it out likely with
the child but the Mandalorian grabs on
before he can make his escape now the
next episode is these season finale and
no doubt they're gonna leave us with a
big cliffhanger I'm gonna throw out two
cliffhangers that could potentially
happen one is that the child is actually
taken in season two is all about getting
them back the other and this is just a
fanboy in me is that will be introduced
to a Jedi or possibly Boba Fett either
way it looks like the Mandalorian is
slowly starting to assemble a team that
will take him on to his journey in
season two I can't wait for the next
episode I hope you enjoyed this video
please be sure to LIKE and subscribe and
leave a comment below with your thoughts
on the series you can also follow me on
twitter at things story whitey
until next time remember I have spoken